peer review is a concept that is
obviously incredibly familiar in the
academic setting you get editorial
review you get people sending stuff back
to you and say fix this fix that we have
this sense that peer review is something
that experts teeth and one of the things
I think that's missed of that image is
the idea that it actually is peer review
in other words everybody is engaged in a
process of judging new work against what
is known and if we all thought more
carefully about that process I think
that we would engage student in this
process much earlier because it will
change their way of thinking about the
nature of knowledge in the field they
need to understand that it is an
everyday or weekly activity in one's
professional life there's always a need
to have somebody else tell you where
you're going off course and done well is
as important to the intellectual process
of the work as what the author is done
nobody writes alone nobody finishes work
alone
[Music]
there's a lot that we've assumed about
instructing students on peer review
process that students would somehow know
how to do it naturally and I think we've
asked them to do too much without giving
them sufficient instruction I wasn't
taught how to do peer review I wasn't
given a course in it I wasn't expected
to look at manuscripts until I became an
editor myself it can be a very
mysterious process and certainly a scary
one which is why we need to talk more
about how it's done and what it involved
it's sometimes very hard for students to
sort of take that first step into self
editing and to editing their peers for a
lot of kids through high school you know
they do their work they hand it in and
they get it back and that's the answer
right and suddenly the answer isn't so
obvious one of the things that students
need to do is move out of a sense that
there is some right answer in the back
of the book or in the professor's head
or somewhere it already exists anytime
that they're actively thinking as
opposed to sitting back and listening to
us becomes much more valuable time in
terms of their gaining expertise
becoming professionalized independent
thinkers I've talked to all of you I
think in conference now on this paper so
you've gotten my feedback and today's
peer review is for you to share feedback
with each other the students in my class
working on each other's drafts what they
were doing was really helping the
writers produce these
ideas to their best possible level they
had exchanged drafts outside of class
and read them and came in prepared to
give that kind of feedback I just
thought you could probably combine the
first paragraph I think I know you're
trying to get out I feel like to explain
to me the point of such a workshop is
more what the students learn from
reading each other's work just to see
what else is out there this is the one
chance they have to read and be read by
someone at their level in a lot of ways
while they care about the grade that I
give them perhaps and in many ways they
care more about what their peers think
that are in the same position as they
are and being able to give them some of
that feedback along with my own I think
it's also apparent anxiety around peer
review happens more in the classroom and
I think it has to do with my presence
that and the fact that they're uncertain
about what I'm looking for and who the
real audience of the paper is so I try
to stress that they're writing for
people who know as much as they do but
haven't gotten their reading their angle
on the material in the cases where we
use peer review in the classroom we will
have students make a presentation for
instance we will inform people
beforehand that they will be asked to
comment on the constructively so that we
can discuss what's useful feedback and
what may not be so useful
I tell students that they get to say I
liked it only once per class they have
to understand that they are
collaborators here and that you know
it's important to notice what's good in
the work but you have to be focused and
specific the biggest point of those
activities is to start making them
should sort of shock their brains into
applying that same level of really
detailed analytical criticism to their
own work and then I think you do get
that Socratic benefit of people real and
discovering within them their own tools
of criticism to help each other
coming into this class I had the notion
that you know if I dedicated more and
more time by myself to a certain essay
that that was going to perfect it but
you know really just one word or one
sentence from someone else can open up
possibilities for me that I would never
have realized no matter how long I spent
you have to have the skills that enable
you to assess not just you know fact by
that content but the quality of the
argument the quality of the structure of
the story or the persuasion that a given
writer is undertaking and you do that by
forcing your students to really dissect
what it is that each other has succeeded
in conveying succeeding in persuading
and where they have failed and why
learning works through the experience of
doing and that's why we should have
students peer-review each other because
it's that process of thinking about the
product and evaluating it in process at
the draft stage maybe and thinking about
collectively having them come together
to brainstorm how this could get
stronger my writing isn't the best and I
know that and when people pointed out to
me it's always surprising and today they
actually showed me how I could actually
fix my essay which was good quite
constructive and hopefully when I go
back and look over my essay I'll be able
to fix those errors which will otherwise
make - a lot better
[Music]
you
[Music]